JARRET.
I HAVE A SOURCE THAT SETTINGED
TO ME AS SHOCK AS THE FOUR-PAGE
MEMO IS GOING TO BE, THE
FOUNDATIONAL INFORMATION BY
WHICH IT WAS WRITTEN ALMOST IS
GOING TO COME ON THE HEELS OF IT
AND IT'S GOING TO BE LIKE A SLOW
DRIP.
THERE ARE THOSE SAYING RELEASE
IT ALL.
WOULD THAT BE A GOOD IDEA?
>> THAT'S WHAT SO MANY OF US
HAVE CALLED FOR.
WE BELIEVE THE MEMO SHOULD BE
RELEASED AND DOCUMENTATION THAT
THIS NOT OPINION, THESE ARE
FACTS ASSEMBLED BY THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND PRESENTED TO THE
MEMBERS OF THAT COMMITTEE.
I HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE IT WILL
PERSUADE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WE
HAVE TO MAKE MAJOR CHANGES IN
NOT ONLY THE PEOPLE CURRENTLY IN
THE AGENCIES OF GOVERNMENT BUT
ALSO IN THE REGULATORY STRUCTURE
SO THIS TYPE OF BEHAVIOR NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN.
>> Sean: IF IT'S A DOCUMENT THAT
CAMPAIGN THAT'S UNVERIFIED ISN'T
THAT BASICALLY STAYING IN DEVIN
NUNES' STATEMENT THE DOSSIER
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY HILARY
AGAINST AN OPPOSING CANDIDATE.
MY READING I THINK IS PRETTY
GOOD.
>> IT WOULD VIOLATE THE TERMS OF
OUR NON DISCLOSURE AGREEMENT.
I CAN SAY MANY OF THE ISSUES --
>> Sean: YOU CAN'T CONFIRM MY
>> UNDOUBTEDLY.
YOU DEMONSTRATE THAT EVERY NIGHT
ON TELEVISION.
>> Sean: SARA CARTER, WHAT WE
SEE TONIGHT IS SO TRANSPARENT
AND OBVIOUS, ROB ROSENSTEIN
WANTS TO LOOK BETTER AND HE'S
HISTORY AND YOU'RE BREAKING NEW
INFORMATION.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
IT APPEARS A CONCERTED EFFORT ON
THE PART OF THE FBI AND MEMBERS
OF THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
AND DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO TRY
TO FORCE THE PRESIDENT TO DELAY
THE RELEASE OF THE MEMO IN AN
EFFORT TO BUY TIME, ACCORDING TO
SOURCES I'VE SPOKEN WITH, TO
LEAK INFORMATION TO DISCREDIT
THE MEMO OR PLACATE THE MEMBERS
OF THE DOJ THAT DON'T WANT TO
SEE THIS RELEASED.
FIND
FIN
FINDING OUT WHAT'S IN THE MEMO
BECAUSE IT NAMES NAMES AND
SHOWED EXTENSIVE FISA ABUSE.
THIS NEEDS TO BE MADE PUBLIC.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT
TO SEE THIS AND THE INTELLIGENCE
PEOPLE I HAVE SPOKEN WITH AND
U.S. OFFICIALS FAMILIAR WITH THE
MEMO SAY THE MEMO IN NO WAY
VIOLATE THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY'S STANDARDS AS FAR AS
DISCLOSING ANYTHING RELATE TO
NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> LET ME INTERRUPT RIGHT THERE,
SEAN, IF YOU'RE TRYING TO
CONVINCE THE PRESIDENT NOT TO
HE SAID HE WAS GOING TO RELEASE
IT AND IMAGINE WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
IF WE DIDN'T.
HE KNOWS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
DEMANDING IT.
>> Sean: GREGG JARRETT I'M
READING DEVIN NUNES' MEMO BACK
IN RESPONSE TO THE FBI.
ROB ROSENSTEIN WITHIN HOURS THEY
WERE LOOK FOR THE DOCUMENT FOR A
YEAR AND HOURS BEFORE THE
DEADLINE ROSENSTEIN BEGGING AND
PLEADING WITH PAUL RYAN DON'T
RELEASE IT AND THE SAME THING IS
GOING ON WITH THE MOMENTO.
I  -- THE MEMO.
I ASSUME YOU HAVE THE SAME
READING SKILLS AND THE DOSSIER
WAS USED TO OBTAIN A FISA
WARRANT AND THE DOSSIER WAS
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES.
>> AND THAT'S DEPRIVATION OF
RIGHTS PUNISHABLE BY 10 YEARS.
YOU CAN'T USE A FALSE DOCUMENT
TO SPY ON SOMEONE.
>> Sean: OR UNVERIFIED.
AND THERE'S OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
LOOK, ROSENSTEIN AND THE FBI
THEY'RE COMPOUNDING THEIR FELONY
BY TRYING TO COVER IT UP.
AND METHODS.
THEY'VE NOW DISPENSED WITH THAT
FICTION AND NOW SAYING, WELL,
THE OMISSIONS.
THEY'VE BEEN TRYING TO OBSTRUCT
A LEGITIMATE INVESTIGATION BY
CONGRESSMAN GAETZ AND OTHERS ON
CAPITOL HILL WHICH HAVE
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITY UNDER
THE CONSTITUTION.
>> Sean: SARA CARTER, LET'S TALK
WITH THE ALTERING OF THE 302s IN
THE McCABE FIRING.
THIS IS BEYOND SERIOUS.
HAVE YOU REPORTING ON THIS.
CAN YOU SHARE IT TONIGHT.
>> WHAT I KNOW IS THIS, I'VE
SPOKEN TO A NUMBER OF SOURCE
WHO'S HAVE SAID McCABE HAD
ACTUALLY ASKED MEMBERS OF THE
CONDUCTS WITH THE WITNESSES --
>> Sean: WHO THEY WANT TO ALTER?
>> I DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
JUST YET UNTIL WE VERIFY IT BUT
THERE'S ONE PERSON IN PARTICULAR
THEY BELIEVE McCABE HAD ASKED
THE FBI AGENT TO ALTER THE 302s.
I THINK THIS IS SIGNIFICANT.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THEY ALTERED THE
302s BUT IF THEY WERE ASKED,
ALLEGEDLY THAT WOULD BE A HUGE
VIOLATION, SEAN.
TOMORROW, THAT MEANS THE DAY
AFTER -- AND THAT MEANS NEXT
WEEK, AND THE WEEK AFTER THAT
WE'RE GOING TO FIND EVEN MORE
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND ANOTHER VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTION HERE IS WHEN THE
WARRANT WAS ISSUED.
WHO KEPT REAUTHORIZING THE
WARRANT OVER AND OVER AGAIN --
>> Sean: WAS IT ROB ROSENSTEIN?
>> THAT WAS A LOT OF DISCUSSION
IT WAS ROB ROSENSTEIN WHO KEPT
REAUTHORIZING THE WARRANT --
>> Sean: THAT WOULD MEAN
ROSENSTEIN, THE GUY THAT
APPOINTED THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
MUELLER COULD HAVE EXTENDED A
FISA WARRANT WITHOUT ASKING YOU
TO REVIEW ANYTHING.
LET'S SAY THAT'S TRUE, DIDN'T IT
MEAN ROBERT MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION WAS BASED ON A
FALSE FISA WARRANT?
>> SEAN, THIS IS AN ISSUE WHERE
MEMO PROVES THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION IS BUILT ON A
FICTION AND NEVER SHOULD HAVE
BEEN STARTED IN THE FIRST PLACE
BUT FOR BAD ACTS.
THAT'S MY VIEW AND I SUSPECT